I have never been this disappointed my
own editor my own flesh and blood have
conspired against me they made a video
behind my back called how to get into
Louie where they make fun of me well
joke's on you brats
I'm making this video and I'm editing it
myself
bet you weren't expecting that huh
basically doing the work that I pay them
to do for them
good job Felix got him you really got
him Felix I'm adding this video to prove
that I don't need you goddamn it I also
had this new air set though it's a
little confusing which one is the real
PewDiePie I can't believe I have to
react to this but let's see what my
editors have to say about me myself and
scythe who is also known as brad2512 -
I've - I'm also Brad one does that make
me Brad three we thought we would go on
PewDiePie submissions and do our own
version of Lawai which has never been
played what they just blatantly rip off
my former line that I spent so hard
coming up with and creating all by
myself god dammit I'm actually so
goddamn prime for the first time in my
life I'm proud of you brats
anyway when meme review next week I
think we should marry hammers already
killed meme review you can't do it god
damn it
meme review wish I also blatantly stolen
do review where we review each other's
at it in on a meme review I'm in Boise
right three is in on the challenge let's
see let's settle this once and for all
who's the strongest brat out there you
think you're the only one that can make
cool explosion effects can make face
look very funny hahahaha no oh yeah I
remember
edit
you legit so shown a meme that Phineas
wasn't even reacting yeah totally
screwed the premiere [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
the camera when mike says holding the
camera I think I need to buy a better
camera alright let's hear his excuse
correct so when I present and premiere
it was fine I exploit it uploaded it and
then people were like why is he so SH
and I was like dude stop hating then I
was like oh wait this one is bad thing
is whether it's good or bad they'll tell
you issues anyway would you try it I
don't care anymore this is a great
testimonial where this channel lists
right now I don't care my editors don't
care we're really putting out the best
content that we possibly can now they
didn't just steal my show they stole my
goddamn intro as well
I'm so proud god damn it what salty love
why I hear you crying we're gonna go on
the pewdiepie submissions and look
there's all these things here there's
this one with him and I don't know who
this person is but we don't want to look
at these because we don't want to see
Felix's face any more than we have to
yeah that's fair that's always something
negative about you it's not even about
all this is come on there's plenty of
positive things about the brats I see it
all the time on the subreddit okay fine
you're right hey what's this Brad before
pewds actually happy Brad now darkness
darkness everywhere see this is what
happens if you edit my videos for too
long why do you think I stopped alright
the fact that Brad one has lasted this
long no one would ever see that coming
we thought he would last six months tops
Brad like every time I see that I'm just
like okay oh my god they actually
admitted it themselves
we now have proof that they do cut it
out every single goddamn video after a
funny meme I say please
bread please don't cut this out it was
so funny and they deserve the
recognition well there you go
they cut it out god damn it three
reasons that your meme doesn't make it
into the why one is copyright content
content in it we can't use it so stop
using copyright content and then be like
because we can't use it because it's
copyright yeah I'm actually really glad
Brad said this another guy who actually
said it either we can't obviously we
can't use copyrighted content stop using
it thank you bright very cool and super
salty wines no any I feel like I'm the
third wheel to a party I wasn't invited
just outside or laughing at this the
second reason is because Felix doesn't
react to it like some of them he'll open
yeah I'm like alright listen I don't
have energy to react to every single guy
okay you know I don't have to make
excuses fight all of these people are
people that are gonna complain to me on
all right number two and three there's
the same thing all right sometimes I've
seen the means already because you guys
tweet them at me and then I don't have a
genuine reaction to it so I'm like a
frigate and in one of these every day
for years has sapped any level of comedy
out of me that I might be able to draw
from one of these things how do you
think I feel probably one of the main
reasons we're doing salty the whoa there
we go
the color correction I'm so bored of
seeing stuff I'm trying to make him look
bad
first of all okay let's just get one
thing straight
he but he does not have you seen how he
flamed turns the camera on regardless
it's almost like I expect you the editor
to frame the shot alright oh look you
actually did it here Wow good job but
that would lose quality like the quality
can get any worse anyway come on learn
color correction listen I know exactly
how to color great I could make a Marvel
movie you gave me enough time Here I am
spending thousands of dollars on epic
new camera I set it up I finally fix it
and they don't even color graded to be
fair I think this is my fault
I think I had the wrong settings and OBS
and I didn't realize but they didn't
correct we'd have a lot of time and if
we do or don't color grade it we still
get paid the same amount for the same
amount of hours of work and either way
Felix won't probably even watch it hey
that's not true but yes that's fair
alright this one says Brad don't cut
this out oh it's one of these right
first of all why is he so done yeah
Fridays with PewDiePie
yes I've seen her before did you see
when he was trying to work out the bun
yeah the phone and I was like I thought
my way of solving it was more fun and
clever okay if you enter the numbers
they do different tones and it would
play the actual theme song that would be
clever instead of just this meme review
bullsh okay yeah I'm a dummy dub if
you're gonna go to the effort to be like
I could fix your color grading yeah at
least make it more natural it looks bro
like actually make it more natural
actually make it more natural also same
orange
yeah that's maybe better color grading
you're right I'm sorry
stir blue George oh I can call her great
it's so easy also can't even call her
great saves face with his legs smhd I'm
the real salty one with this as well
I've seen this man but I didn't edit
this you do
yes is this the genuine confusion
marzia to this video wait mine says Brad
three I'll bread for my sense the only
one that can save the quality of this
channel please maybe we are and maybe
next time when we search Brad or scythe
or something there will be better there
has to be I'm actually the moderator of
the PDP subreddit so I don't think so
okay
there will be instable all right well
old memes are sound side i am actually
proud of my branch my good old braids
it's all jokes we're all just making
silly jokes with each other and i'm the
butt of the joke well joke's on you
Brad's cuz I edited this video and it
was great
goddamnit I have to edit this video now
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay
I'll cut you a deal the game is
available for free and that's a great
price
[Music]
okay I edited the video it was
absolutely awful premier kept crashing I
hate this I'm sorry Brad 1 & 2 I take
back all the mean things I said please
keep editing my videos Brad for is
officially retiring bye